well here we go again off the back of
the Duke and Duchess of sussex's
six-hour Netflix series now two more
interviews with Prince Harry both filmed
in California where he now lives timed
to maximize publicity for his new book
what's left to say upon to journalist
and friend Tom bradby this I never
needed to be this way the leaking and
the planting I want a family not an
institution they feel as though it's
better to keep us somehow as the
villains they've shown absolutely no
willingness to reconcile
in program teasers he talks of wanting
his father and his brother back but his
words are in reality set to make life
difficult again for the royal family
alluding it would seem to claims he made
in his docu-series accusing his
brother's office of allegedly briefing
against him every single time I've tried
to do it privately there have been
briefings and leakings and planting of
stories against me and my wife and that
correspondent will literally be
spoon-fed information and write the
story and then the bottom of it they
will say that they've reached out to
Buckingham Palace for comment but the
whole story is Buckingham Palace
commenting so when we're being told for
the last six years we can't put a
statement out to protect you but you do
it for other members of the family there
becomes a point when silence his
betrayal
with grand claims about explosive
Revelations coming just weeks on from
their documentary series just how
damaging will this be I would go back to
the drawing board looking at history
look at what happened to the abdicated
King I did the eighth if you are to
survive with your princely entitlement
and expectations outside monarchy you
have to earn a living and arguably this
is
this is a lucrative way for Harry to get
his message out there and he's not
finished yet with the TV interviews time
to air two days before his book comes
out could the greater Revelations come
in print little has been leaked about
what Prince Harry has written in the
first of what's reportedly a four book
deal worth around 30 million pounds but
if the royal family were hoping for a
quieter start to 2023 well it looks like
princess Harry will be bringing the new
year fireworks Katie Spencer Sky News